[Music]
[Applause]
the
wwe it'll be wrestlemania
and uh the miz taking on bad bunny in a
tag team matchup during wrestlemania
this saturday streaming exclusively on
peacock
uh sign up at peacocktv.com
and uh we'll talk to the miz i think
he's joining us now
uh let me start with this i know you're
from ohio
and uh i'm from ohio i went to the
university of dayton so i
i wasn't smart enough to get into the
school you went it to uh
university of miami of ohio like
yourself
we are the harvard of the midwest oh i
know i mean i don't mean to brag about
it or anything but you know
oh go figure that you would brag about
something there ms
i mean they did call it j crew you so i
mean they have any nicknames the harvard
of the midwest and j crew you or the two
that uh
i always went by how did how close did
this
come to not even happening this career
honestly it it came basically
if i did not get on the real world i
don't think any of this would have been
possible because
um i think getting on the real world
opened my mind to say you know what you
could do stuff and in the entertainment
world like i'm from parma ohio when
you're from parma ohio
you know you go to college you get after
college you go back home you get a job
you get a family and that's what you do
for the rest of your life
and that's kind of the the mode i was in
like i went to miami ohio for business
not for entertainment not for theater
and so
i um yeah i mean if i didn't get on the
real world i would not be sitting here
i'd probably be working at my dad's mr
hero
how do you find your personality in
wrestling
i think it's time i think it's uh
confidence i think it's finding uh your
voice
i think once you find your voice i think
it's like acting when you're finding a
new character you find the way they walk
the way they talk
how they act what what drives them what
motivates them
um and so that's kind of where you you
start
and then you know i've been doing this
the miz for 16 years now in wwe
and so it's kind of the second nature
for me
did you sample from other wrestlers
growing up i think everyone does i think
that's the uh
when you're first training to be a wwe
superstar
they say take from your favorites so my
favorites growing up or like the
ultimate warrior now granted i didn't
paint my face
i don't paint my face right now but when
i was a kid you better believe i was
painting my face like the ultimate
warrior putting streamers on my arm and
running around the house and knowing my
mom
um and then like the rock um austin
um all my favorites you know i try to
try to take
little samples from them but also i
still want to be my own
original character an original miz and
so
i think i've done a a good job at a fine
line of of fine-tuning myself and making
sure that uh
i give an originality to my character
let me give you the power to go back and
wrestle anybody one time who would it be
ultimate warrior i never got to wrestle
him and he was my all-time favorite as a
kid growing up i mean
i i looked at him and he was just larger
than life
and huge and just big personality big
energy as soon as he came out of the uh
out of the gate you he was running he
had this
unbridled like energy that you couldn't
match and
i just was so entertained by him but do
you want to beat your idol
would you been okay losing 100 i would
want to beat or get beaten by my idol uh
either
either or it does not matter uh
i have gotten beaten by like a person
that i looked at i i've gotten beaten by
the rock
uh that was a pretty interesting um take
i mean wrestlemania 27 i'm in the main
event of wrestlemania
i'm holding the wwe championship i beat
the uh the poster child of wwe and john
cena
with the rock's help and then after that
the rock rock bottomed me give me a
people's album
what's the hardest hit you ever got the
hardest what
hit actually that at that wrestlemania i
uh i got
tackled off of like a table onto a
concrete
uh floor and my head smacked on the
floor
and i got i was i could not remember
anything i was knocked out
and uh and yeah it was it was insane
it was insane i think i think any time
you do anything with your brain
that's one of the mo that's the hardest
thing that you could possibly do explain
the art of falling
the art to falling okay sure so when uh
when you're first learning how to become
a wwe superstar or a professional
wrestler
you learn how to fall and the object is
to
fall flat on your back uh with your arms
flat out so
basically you and you got to watch your
head and obviously when your arms go
flat out
your back muscles kind of tense up and
so it make it allows your head not to
slap snap
and so i didn't do that that time at
wrestlemania 27.
you and your wife rehearse things since
she's arrested
you know we rehearse things uh in the
ring in the bed whatever
so yeah i mean we definitely rehearsed
uh my wife is uh one of the longest
reigning uh
champions uh in wwe history and she's
she's done a tremendous job uh with her
character and doing her thing
in wwe as well so it's always nice to
have your wife like when my wife was
like kind of like my manager
you know whenever you have your wife by
your side
and you know the person you love and
you're wearing like a speedo you kind of
want to show off in the ring
and i feel like that was like the best
time that i've had
uh as a wwe superstar because you know i
was always every every
every week you know i show off in front
of the audience but when your wife is
standing right
there you know you give them a little
extra
what do fans say to you when they see
you on the street or see you
uh outside of the ring i get a lot of uh
yells
a lot of awesome people doing my
catchphrases
uh correct is my new one uh
i basically asked john my my tag team
partner john morrison a question
and the answer is always correct and uh
it gets
really annoying but that's my job to
annoy an audience and but
the thing is once something is really
annoying it starts gets it starts to
catch on
and you start to do it and uh so yeah i
mean anytime everyone ans
john asks me a question it's always
correct correct
cool right
how are you stupid honey gets over how
do you put your game
face on you know athletes always talk
about when you go into the
the uh football field or whatever it
might be you got to kind of
gear up for that you're gearing up for
something
that is competitive um but how do you
put that i'm mad
you know you know moments before that
you get into character
i think it's a we have a position called
the gorilla position
it's right before we go out it's where
all uh
people are watching uh the show and
telling us how much
how much time there is you know uh what
what we're gonna be doing next
so there's that little area right before
we go out to the ramp when our music
hits
uh usually i'm very nervous uh i have
butterflies in my stomach i can't even
talk
sometimes i feel like i'm gonna faint uh
you know because emotions are running so
high
you know you never know what's going to
happen in wwe it's not like it's not
like a concert
where they play the same song every
single every single day
it's a new match a new thing going on
each and every time it's a new it's a
new
crowd as well and our crowd is
interactive they boo who they hate they
cheer who they love
and you never really know what you're
gonna get and so
when you go out there you know you hear
the reaction and once i hear that
reaction
all those nerves go away and it turns
into this
immense amount of energy adrenaline and
i
feed off of it and i just
i really enjoyed and now with
wrestlemania
uh coming up on saturday and sunday you
know
it's the first time we've had a live
audience in over a year
yeah so i cannot wait to feel the
electricity
of that audience to to feel that energy
now granted wwe did a great job with the
virtual
audience uh you know we have a virtual
crowd in a place we called the thunder
dome
and they've done a great job at making
it feel like a live audience but having
the real life human beings
in that crowd it's going to be amazing
and uh
you're working with snickers uh yeah
their role in this is what
so sneaker uh wrestlemania is presented
by snickers
and uh and at dollar general you can get
my snickers bar which i think is
incredible it says awesome on it my
catchphrase is i'm the miz and i'm
awesome
so you can go to dollar general and you
can get a candy bar
this is awesome on it and it's dedicated
to me
and i cannot believe like never in my
wildest dreams when i was growing up as
a kid
you know going to convenience and
getting myself snickers bar did i ever
think
a sneakers bar would be dedicated to me
so it's pretty incredible
and uh i'm always very thankful for all
the opportunities i'm presented
and i'm just very thankful you know i
love i love snickers and uh
they do a great job and i got my own
stickers bar it's kind of cool
when's the last time you had a wardrobe
malfunction oh i haven't had
very serious wardrobe malfunctions but i
have seen
a person so one of the things a bad guy
will do
is grab the tights because it's illegal
and throw a person because it's easier
to throw a person when you grab onto
their clothes
one time a guy grabbed on to the
person's speedo or tights as we call
them
he ripped him off he didn't like they
just
came right off and the guy was just
standing there
butt naked and you you hear the crowd
and it's live by the way you don't get
two tanks so you hear the crowd just go
absolute silence
and you hear one lady go
and then everyone else starts erupting
but this poor
guy was just whole and the other guy
that was wrestling him had no idea
that the guy was naked like had no idea
and i don't know how he didn't know
but he didn't know i'm guessing the
woman who's laughing
that's not a good thing if you're the
guy who's naked
[Laughter]
so what happens to bad bunny this
weekend at wrestlemania
i feel sorry for him because you know i
don't i don't feel sorry for him i feel
sorry for his fans
because they're probably not going to
hear him sing in probably a good year
because that's
the amount a lot of time it's going to
take for the wire out of his jaw to come
out when i'm done punching him wow
so uh but yeah it's one of those things
where
you know he came for a performance and
he overstayed his welcome
and he beat down the wrong door
uh and now no matter how many times he
has i mean honestly
bad bunny is one of the biggest
recording artists out there right now he
just won a grammy
uh he has over a billion views on all
his videos
in youtube like just one of his video
has a billion views like not a
not a pam that's not a million that's a
billion so the guy is wildly famous has
a huge
fan base but he doesn't understand that
at wrestlemania this
is our super bowl our our world series
our nba finals and we honestly feel it's
bigger than that it's the greatest
spectacle you will ever see
you take away moments that'll last a
lifetime it's just the sad part is
that bad bunnies fans are going to take
away a moment that they're not going to
want to see
and he's not going to want to feel
because i am one of the best
of all time i'm the only two-time grand
slam champion in the history of wwe
and i plan on showcasing that at
wrestlemania
he's the greatest wrestler ever from the
uh university of
or miami university miami you are the
best wrestler to ever come out of there
is that correct
uh you know i i would say so i would say
i'm almost the
um uh one of the most famous people ever
to come out of
miami university of ohio but you know it
all depends on what sport you like
like some people like basketball where
they'll say wally zerbiak is
some people like football well they say
ben roethlisberger is
um but uh you know i like to pat myself
on the back and say
well i'm the biggest i'm waiting for the
broadway musical les miz
how are we all you know i'm waiting for
them to give me a call and uh maybe i
can go over there and uh
since i am the miz be les miz for once
mike thanks for getting up with us and
uh have fun this weekend we appreciate
your time
thank you very much yeah definitely tune
in to wrestlemania as presented by
snickers
uh saturday sunday april 10th and 11th
and if you want to
april 12th is monday and
my show my reality show ms and mrs is
coming back with all new episodes on the
usa network
at 11 p.m you're not gonna want to miss
it it's a family-friendly show
it'll make you laugh out loud and it's
fun it's entertaining
so thank you so much for having me i
really appreciate it thank you miss
have a go that's the miz he's uh he's
wrestling bad bunny coming up on
saturday night on peacock